I started a patriotic,
it's another way to support me.
The first is to watch my videos.
The second is to share them with
friends.
And the third is to back this channel
with money.
You don't have to do this,
you're not a second class viewer.
If you don't become a patron,
these videos will always be free.
But I do want to give you,
if you're able and don't mind signing up
for yet another website,
the opportunity to help me take this
small one man channel to the next level.
What do I mean?
Well here on coffee break,
I do everything on a shoe string budget.
Ever noticed there's not much pizazz in
these videos and not much Polish.
Not to mention a while back people saw
me buying Maxwell House coffee.
What with your support we can get better
fuel for these videos and we can get
some much needed Polish.
So let's talk a little bit more about
the site.
The website patrion originally comes
from the word patron,
which has Roman origins and it's a word
for some wealthy person who supported
and artists to do his work.
And while it may be a stretch to call my
work art,
it isn't a stretch to become one of my
patrons because there's only two levels
of support,
$1 a month and $5 a month.
$1 a month is less than the cost of a
hot and spicy chicken at Mcdonald's.
The standard metric of value back from
my college days and if you choose to
support my channel with his amount,
you'll be joining the proletariat
members of the coffee break economy.
You are the backbone of everything we
will achieve in this channel from here
on out,
and I want to thank you sincerely.
If you choose me over a delicious
sandwich,
I'd be torn over the dilemma myself.
The second level of support is $5 a
month.
This is some big papa dollars and
roughly equal to your average trip to
starbucks if you choose to support me
instead of buying yourself a frothy
caffeine infused beverage,
you've achieved true self sacrifice for
this,
you will rise to the prestigious rank of
the Burj Wallasey,
a member of the burrs.
Rosie is not fundamentally different
from the proletariat in any way,
but they think they're better people and
they definitely have more money for
being in either group.
You will get a title that you can load
over people in or discord as well as
when we start our separate it.
You can have your title there as well.
Over time,
I also will be releasing patrion
exclusive videos and more.
Please note there are no material perks
associated with being in either of these
groups other than my sincere gratitude
for supporting me,
but I do plan on fostering some healthy
class warfare between the two.
So if you were going to support me
anyways and you want the fun of
belonging to a community and the joys of
hating outsiders for no reason,
this is the Patrion free you goals.
Now for my goals,
I'm going to keep it simple at $150 a
month.
My monthly coffee needs,
we'll have been met.
Yes,
I drink too much coffee.
I should cut back and yes,
I can quit anytime I want it to.
It's just that now isn't really a great
time.
You know,
quit judging me,
but my big goal and it is a big one,
is to get $3,000
a month.
This gets me to the place where I can
officially drop my day job and do this
full time.
It would also increase my videos per
month from about one to one and a half
per month to more like three to four per
month and it would mean I could create
bigger and more ambitious videos.
This is my dream goal and it's where I
want to be.
I find the work that I do on coffee
break to be extremely meaningful.
I love stimulating conversations,
telling stories and diving into research
topics and if you'll help me,
I want to do more of it.
Ultimately don't know what to expect
from all this.
It's kind of an experiment.
People have been mentioning that they
want to support my channel,
but I don't know how big of a minority
of my channel that is.
If none of you guys support the channel,
that's fine.
I'll keep making videos,
but if you can and want to,
I sincerely thank you and I'm excited to
see where this journey takes us.
Okay.